[Music]
pyrotechnician
I'm Greg Alva Ksenia yes Kelly Kelly so
hey I don't know what happened I found
out a fun fact before filming this guy's
her voice can be heard in the Justice
League movie somewhere what's your line
I announced that the death of the
supermen was supposed to bring people in
together and then it didn't it only
divided everyone so you guys can you say
that in English well I say it in English
with the Russian accent and then in
Russian as well but I think the English
version is in it you guys got a go
comment below whoever finds it and you
win we're gonna watch a couple of TV
spots from Aquaman a movie I'm very much
looking forward to first ones called
waves second one's called attitude I'm
sure you guys already seen the official
test for this but every once in a while
I do like check it out these TV spots
before we hop into that I wanted to say
thank you to everyone for fonts on our
patreon page over there with your TV
show reactions q and A's and music video
coverage so go check that out as soon as
you can you guys ready to see some
shirtless Jason Momoa oh yes he's trying
to get to my body status hopefully one
day Jason we're buddy I call him Jake
buddy you got fish boy from the TV
swish man you could unite our world
Sunday
[Music]
Wow
hero
a lot over that shot
50:13 see the extended video on YouTube
now alright okay really quick let's go
to the attitude one before we do
anything else
[Music]
something more
[Music]
but city
[Music]
these headaches qz is that what he
saying do you guys see the extended trip
Wow that is very impressive you lived in
Italy for a little bit you spoke Italian
just how did Wow so did you uh yeah miss
Clewes II definitely well I've said a
lot of opinions about Aquaman lately but
why don't you guys share your opinions
to the world right now sure I mean no do
some ammo I feel like it's just in every
man everyone loves him because he's down
to earth and he's a rugged man it's
great I can definitely relate to Jason
we have the same level of charm the same
level of confidence I could probably
bicep curl a little bit more than him
but yeah that like yeah my mom I got to
identify that to my MA all that reminds
me of Nicole Kidman my Filipino mother
oh she looks just like a white blonde
Australian woman what if I was here
what's your opinion Aquaman I'm excited
I don't know that much about it actually
it's it's I saw once that trailer I'm
excited to see all the characters in the
world they created I feel like it's
really cool that's that's what always
makes me happy is that there's a world
in it and the water characters - yeah
interesting characters I feel like some
of this might be cheesy but it seems
like the good kind of cheese you know
it's usually the daytime shots when
they're like not in water and you see
her with that wig the one that Amber
Heard has the red one and there's
certain shots really like this looks
like kind of corny this looks a little
cartoony but but it looks charming to me
it looks amusing like I'm one of the
people who I know this is not gonna feel
anything like the Justice League movie
but I'm someone who actually defends
that movie because I really enjoyed the
hell out of it I thought was a lot of
fun
I think that this movie will probably
have that same level of fun even in the
moments that might be a little bit on
the corny side I have faith that
regardless it's gonna be very amusing
I'm always down to watch a journey if a
guy are into being a king it's your
self-discovery journey exactly like I
said identify so much with this movie
it's a ridiculous how I feel like I'm
the way how the black community felt
with black panther is how I feel with
watching Jason Momoa let's let's say yes
oh and get a good knot out of that yeah
I I would every movie the rocks it's
cool to see them going through the
jungle video game yeah yeah I also
wonder if it's like the good kind of
corny or not like what you said makes
sense like cuz you never know some of
them you're watching them because all
the trailers like especially for these
kind of movies are like they're all the
same kind of right so this is always
like nothing if it's actually gonna be
cool or not trailers tend to like
sometimes presented differently sound
carries yeah I mean from watching so
many trailers of the same movie you get
pretty good at determining like what
will the tone of the movie be and I feel
like they've been pretty consistent with
their marketing for this and the
extended video they're talking about I
did do a reaction to that
that one really gave you a good glimpse
at what the style of this movie will be
and that gave me so much feet and what
this movie is gonna look like I'm I love
going I'm at have you guys been to IMAX
ever yeah and to me this is the exact
movie I would want to watch on IMAX just
that level of scope and world building
all in one it just seems so incredible
to me
are you a 3d lover I'm not a 3d love me
[Music]
I do actually it's so funny because I
worked on a 3d movie a while back it
kind of like yes no it was the
russian-ukrainian movie there was 3d
comedy oh that's really cool
celery B comedy yeah yeah and they tried
something new look what Jackass did that
too but their's was like action exactly
but now you want those punchlines really
popping out of it is I think it's just
it became better than all over the years
but it's something new isn't that cool
though how it didn't stick like the same
way as them like the sound and in color
from when they appeared in cinema I'm
going some deep hashtag dude when they
first appear way back and it's not as
cat I agree I understand why cuz it just
makes you is that why is that way wait
wait wait I thought she did a green now
she's agreeing I'm asking why why do I
throw up from 3d you know why don't you
like it
I know it's just like I don't like I'm
art and I get over sensitized and avatar
I was like I'm about to yak when they
were writing the beautiful oh it makes
you nauseous kind of yeah yeah I love
that you can you're almost in the world
like you can almost reach and touch like
especially avatar the opening shot the
twisting one yeah yeah I was like
[Laughter]
well we're all gonna go watch Aquaman
together in 3d so probably can throw up
and that's what we call Greg really
trying hard to make this tangent back to
the main conversation and greatly
failing to do so I can touch things yeah
remember at CEO at Disneyland remember
Captain EO at Disneyland ago back in the
day okay we're too young for it but my
brother it was a three it was one of the
first 3d movies is that Disneyland and
it was Michael Jackson Captain EO is
super freaking scary and my brother like
punched the scary character and punch
the lady in back oh well that is so cool
yeah we are gonna be the best people to
go watch Aquaman with this December
people coming this December what's
happening I think I should move this
discussion of 3d and vomiting to the
beginning of the video to make everyone
happy yes really if you've ever been
queasy please comment below from a 3d
movie it's sure I've been I've been in
for queasy in general some good good
audience to the real rejects follow them
on Instagram where they are vomiting all
the time on their stories it's great
stuff if that's what gets you going and
yeah see you later
[Music]